hey stop
i didn't think this would be an
emotional leader
i can't have a compliment and we can't
handle emotions
uncomfortable
you stupid
[Music]
hello and welcome to the episode where
we're all trying to show our vaginas if
you're listening on audio you might want
to listen on youtube to see which one
shows
well and listen don't just mute it okay
rude
rude but if you do that's fine just give
us a view we get it but why are we
dressed up i'm going i'm getting there
let me host the show i'm just really
excited i'm sorry okay
i like to draw it out i just want to say
i'm not a [ __ ] because i'm not showing
toes
no free toes no free toes no free toes
oh my goodness
not for free don't pay me
all right so we are here
dressed up
because
it's our
100th episode
[Applause]
how did we do a hundred of these
did you listen to all 100 if not
actually back we might have done more
than a hundred we have some reason
in every episode you have to go back and
find them all you have to like clip them
all together and it'll spell out a
message it's a puzzle
that's where we hid the holy grail we
put all our phone numbers in there so
the holy grail is our nudes
in a box somewhere so you can figure it
out
cheers cheers we're the only ones
drinking
all right um who do we got we got tiff
here and jess of course and nikki
we got gina
and we have all of you because we asked
you on our instagram if you're not
following us please follow us at big
mood girls we frequently ask you for
different prompts and stuff sometimes
you get questions on the show you know
sometimes we get reviewed dating
profiles and this time we put out our
big mood phone number and we asked you
to leave us some voice messages because
we're lonely we're all very lonely
spread out across la and the country
actually i'm not in l.a anymore
i'm in somewhere else
but uh yeah so you did that and you left
us your beautiful beautiful voice
messages and we're going to hear them
for the first time
we did not pre-play these because the
google thing gives us like a transcript
so we're like okay like people left
voice messages but let's not hear them
yet yeah so you could read what you were
saying in a little bit poorly google
translate like it was all jacked up yeah
it was like i hope you're dead
maybe they said that but i don't think
so yeah
i'm so excited for tiffin case's baby
but i hope you're dead
google needs work on their translate
whatever you said we picked it so we'll
see what that's it um all right and some
of you asked for advice questions we
just said ask us questions leave us
messages whatever you want free for just
a celebration episode you hear our voice
all the time now we're going to hear
your voice oh that's cute and we're
going to like judge it and we're going
to judge yourself
i swear to god i didn't stand up for
this
if you have a lisp you're about to get
judge sword because i drink wine i'm
just kidding she's gonna join you in the
list
you have a cute little list it's like
not a full lisp but it's like a little
tiny one half list a half half house she
just has a shirt
okay okay hopefully this works because i
have not played messages from here yet
technical difficulties let's hear the
message
i want to hear the first message the
first method okay everybody shut up okay
all of those be quiet
hosts i don't like being quote
um
i hope i've got the big mood podcast
if so i just want to say
um congratulations on your 100th episode
thank you and um
it's really given myself i'm twined by
the way just um
yeah some things to watch about and
seeing things from a different angle
especially from a female perspective
with a lot of the topics um you will
discuss
um
yeah so just keep up the good work and i
[ __ ] love the australian accent
somewhere i am hearing new zealand is it
yeah is it new zealand or is it british
that us blokes
uk
what's happening
[Music]
and we like it he doesn't they didn't
say their voice i think he did i missed
it it sounded like he did a little bit
when he said his name i thought he said
i heard tom i don't know i could be
wrong
hmm
i was so i was so like filled with joy
at hearing his voice i was like same
cool that i kind of like missed some of
it but i was like oh i love your accent
that's all i was thinking i was actually
surprised that the first one was the
mail yeah i was like you know because we
don't know we i assumed like there's a
lot of females listening but yeah
so i was so happy when he said congrats
to your hundreds because because of the
fact that we're all like dressed up it's
like we're celebrating but yeah like
hearing him say like congrats it's like
oh my god you guys are really
celebrating with us yeah i hope you're
all drunk by the end of this episode we
should have a drinking game every time
someone says
big mood oh god you got a drink every
time someone says 100 okay oh yeah
that's even crazy 100 drinks everyone
everything
anytime someone says the the
okay whoa that was close mr wine we like
your accent please leave me a voicemail
on my instagram reading me a bedtime
story it's very comforting me too well
we can share it
next message
yes i want to say uh the voice message
thing was a great idea by the way my
name is holly hi holly um
there's probably a million questions i
could ask right now but if anything i
want to say how much i love all of you
and i enjoy watching your friendship
i find it odd sometimes when i myself uh
talking about
you all with my boyfriend
nikki says this just said that
i love that look at this ridiculous meme
dean of shares yeah because if y'all are
my real friends
i kind of joke that you are to be honest
um
yes i did chat with you from time to
time i actually did make the move to
texas
um and i found clarity in my
relationship but i am in dallas
uh it's so much better than northern
virginia and people are so much more
kind um
i hope to find real life friends here
too
i grew up in virginia so it's a pretty
big deal yeah moving that
for you guys keep those voice messaging
episodes coming
um and especially on my journey
to
uh rediscovering myself and what i want
to do with my life
uh i just totally scripted this i hope
it doesn't sound
weird no no no no no super natural
i love you
we love you molly you've been so scared
and now she's a texan yeah
she's talked to you a couple times no
i'm not crying
jess
[Applause]
it's weird to like actually realize that
there's like real people watching us
like hearing the voices yeah i'm like oh
wait there's like real people watching
us yeah it's not just like a fake like
we're not just doing this and no one's
act like sometimes i feel like we just
do this yeah and then i don't i don't
see the people though like i don't know
who i'm talking to or who even knows
that i exist yeah and then to hear like
a real person being like oh sometimes i
like share what you said with my
boyfriend and i'm like oh my god like
people are thinking about like you with
the big bang theory
i'm just upset because the big bang
theory did not nail like she say factory
at all i used to work in cheese yeah
it didn't look anything like that maybe
they didn't want to get sued true yeah
but they use the name yeah
that's weird
no that's really sweet i love hearing
yeah me too and then like also like
hearing their message and and seeing
like how we have impacted
people's lives like that's really what
makes me love this yeah yeah the most
exactly that's why we started
i just kind of realized that people
listened to our show just like today
just now i like just now realize that
people are listening to me
i didn't even think anyone was listening
to this i mean for the first half of the
show it was bots that i bought for us
these are really good bonds yeah these
are really super good bots
yeah how much did you pay for the
expensive package
now these are the ais
these are the ai's and i'm down yeah
things yeah they actually improve they
guys can make you feel things this is
great
do we know how many we got in total and
there's like almost 100. we only asked
one day because i was like we should ask
multiple days but no i was like that's
too many
so i think there was like it was just on
this story so it was yeah it was really
temporary oh no wait wait it isn't well
in case you guys are you guys want to
leave us more the number is on our
instagram contact page like the contact
button yeah at big mood girls
661-360-6950
[Music]
it's nice to hear people's voices
because sometimes reading text to you
don't hear the tone yeah behind it
that's true yeah it's like way different
now i'm like getting emotional hearing
their actual voices
i'm so lonely give me a call oh gosh
later you're such a [ __ ]
hot singles near you today that's a good
voice you should be a phone sex operator
just munching on cheetos yeah what do
you like about my crunching picture her
in this dress each time yeah yeah
yeah
definitely not real life okay you guys
ready for the next one yeah okay
hi my name is bonnie and i just want to
leave a message for miss gina darling
that's my body i just want to say thank
you for all that you do and thank you
for streaming it was through your stream
that got me through really dark times
and through your streams i was able to
meet my amazing husband and i am now
happily ever this is you
i just want to say thank you for
everything and love you so much take
care and always stay the same oh
that's so sweet
bonnie has been a part of my stream
community for a long time
and in my community she met another guy
he goes by braves online and they
started talking he lived like in the
midwest or somewhere and she lived in
california she's a she's a um
a special ed teacher here
and they met on my stream they started
talking next thing you know they started
dating and now they're married and he
lives in california
and he's like he delivers mail in like
our hood and stuff and like it's the
cutest thing and they've always been so
supportive i'm talking like if i tell my
stream that i'm sick they like bonnie
and braves would send me like cold
medicine they would like they took such
good care of me like it's the sweetest
thing in the world and
they're so kind it's it's it's [ __ ] i
love them a lot that's awesome see these
things make they all feel like why did
we play
we're like those instagram apps where
you we like it that shows the mascara
that's us thank you bonnie i love you
guys so cute but we're such an all
female show yeah because we're so
emotional right now we are so it's very
water in here it's really overreacting
and being really emotional right we're
filming this well the sun is in scorpio
the stars are in scorpio right now
intense water science very emotional
okay it lets you process your emotions
okay jupiter is in merengue
hey guys thank you for calling for a big
mood my name is
i am
um this isn't any a type of advice i
just wanted to share something that i
feel like i've been
wanting for so long recently i saw that
tiff is pregnant and she's been doing so
good through her journey
and
i just want to say that i'm on that same
boat
congrats congratulations oh they're
trying
well still congratulations
i'm so happy for you guys i love
watching you guys
uh tiff i wish you a happy healthy
pregnancy
and for the rest of the big girls i love
you guys
i wish i could meet you guys
i put a lot of black on i know i just
put so much black around your eyes
that's so sweet
i didn't think this would be an
emotional yeah
[Applause]
now you know what it feels like i don't
want to cry in the club thank you for
that yeah that's so sweet and i i wish
you the best of luck yeah
and oh my gosh hopefully by the time you
hear this even
yeah you'll have to update us
yeah
okay
next one hi big news girls this is
sylvia um i just wanted to let you guys
know that you have been my support when
i did not have any and i appreciate you
guys so much i'm so happy that you guys
have a podcast i'm so happy
um that you guys are happy i've been
following you since jk and
i will probably always be following you
guys
um even though i don't know you i love
you
oh
nicki thank you
that's so sweet
we love you
why are we doing the sources
oh man we can't have a compliment we
can't handle emotions
i need to like get rid of all this love
uncomfortable next episode you stupid
you can't handle love love venus is
trining with uranus
hi my name is kalina and i just wanted
to say thank you for putting out such
great content it's super fun to watch
whenever i work overnight and
it's doing so entertaining
i find that the advice that you guys
give is really helpful but here's to 100
more episodes thank you
thank you dang she works overnight yeah
be safe
scary i don't know what you do but be
safe and we love you yeah i love you so
much yes thank you so much for night
jobs so you go in when it's when the
sun's still out and then you come out
and the sun's out again yeah that's
right
or maybe they go on the jump start
that's a job
thank you for listening to us
during those shifts
yeah jiminy christmas okay she's so cute
things you say you you mouth good
your mouth is your mouth good thanks
okay
teddy keeps one of my little teeny tiny
titties want to keep falling out
and i'm crying and then like can't teddy
popping out
[Laughter]
and i'm from
just wanted to australia
i love you guys i've been watching you
guys um well over five years you know
everywhere that you guys are on
um and
yeah big move gets me through like
almost every one of my shifts at work i
work at a grocery store and i sneakily
chuck in one headphone and i'm just like
listening to you guys talk about
everything while i'm serving customers
and
you just help me throughout my days so
i've been saying i love you all has been
having a wonderful day and congrats on
your hundredth episode
i will try to watch it
[Music]
bye-bye
i just i love this too because it really
paints a picture like she's at work like
yeah
in her ear while she's at work that's so
interesting in australia like around the
world
that's [ __ ] crazy like helping
customers and she's sneakily listening i
think i love australians like they're so
i mean even even if they're mean i feel
like they sound so nice
like everything they mean their tone is
just so like cool yeah even when they're
flustered they're like they speak up to
like and i had a really good day yeah
yeah and i'm like i'm sorry i couldn't
listen to you all day long
i want to hear your podcast every time i
do a tour in australia like they really
show out dude they're they're so
supportive
it's burped it's new
and emotionally she's just burped in her
ear while she's just helping customers
right i'm sorry rude i'm sorry i hope
you like that
and they always show up and they're like
the sweetest things and they're they
come bearing a [ __ ] ton of gifts
i have tim tams language
i have enough tim tams to last me until
like i'm 90 dude like you guys can bear
me in sometimes
they're so awesome that's awesome does
the toilet really go the other way yeah
it does test it out are you [ __ ]
really really
looks weird in my head i was so
determined that i recorded my toilet at
home went to australia just to compare
like
yeah that's different that's definitely
yeah
that's funny why does it do that i don't
know something earth
and they're and like they're so opposite
so so winter time for us is summer time
for them yeah so they're they're
christmases
and they have a christmas roast and
everything that's cute wow so cute
speaking of the holidays you'll probably
want some cute outfits exactly that's
where stitch fix comes in thank you
nikki so your style isn't one size fits
all it's about what suits your body and
what suits the moment so why not shop at
a store that is personalized to your
size and your style specifically for you
that's where stitch fix freestyle comes
in a shop built just for you stitch fix
freestyle is your trusted style
destination where you can discover and
instantly buy
curated items based on your style likes
and lifestyle whether you're looking for
a brand you love or try a new one
at stitch fix freestyle you can shop a
range of over a thousand brands
personalized to your size and fit with
styles for workouts to work wear for
lounging around the house or for a night
out kind of like what we're wearing
tonight
stitch fix freestyle has clothes for any
occasion
plus there's no subscription required
and they offer free shipping returns and
exchanges get started today by filling
out your style quiz at stitchfix.com
mood that's
stitchfix.com mood to try stitch fix
freestyle stitchfix.com
mood what's better than a hundred
episodes a hundred percent clean booty
uh let's talk about the gift that keeps
on giving the hellotissy bidet it cleans
your butt way better than wiping cuts
your toilet paper use by 80
it also saves trees and all the
thousands of gallons of water used to
convert them into toilet paper and it
comes with a book full of poop jokes my
butt is in love god i love this company
they're the greatest they send us shirts
that say um ask me about my butthole
literally
i didn't get that i'm having good
marketing
yeah
they're having such a good time
marketing over there yeah um and you
guys know i'm a huge huge advocate for
bidets ever since i went to japan i feel
like everyone should have a bidet and if
you don't have one yet get to it because
your butt butt so stop smearing poop on
your butt crap yeah seriously
uh stop spreading your business around
your butthole with toilet paper start
washing with hello tishi hello tissue
bidet washes your butt butt with fresh
water for a way better clean than toilet
paper simply spray and pat dry it
attaches to your existing toilet no
electrician or plumber needed it
installs in less than eight minutes and
it cuts down your tpus by 80
saving money and paper waste join the
millions of happy hello tissue customers
right now who take care of their yule
logs the dignified way
they're great uh give the gift of a
clean bum to you or your loved ones this
holiday season and get 10 off plus free
shipping right now at hellotissue.com
big mood that's hellotissue.com big mood
for 10 off and free shipping clean your
butt butt yeah clean that butt butt yeah
all right now that you all have clean
butt butts because you went and got a
hello tissy congrats oh wait hold on do
their clocks also go count counter
clockwise
yeah
you guys are the smartest we went to
school
yeah stay in your life leave the bimbos
to us okay
the only smart one okay you don't have
to get in there you should kick me off
yeah
get off the ship
rose and jack there's only room for one
[ __ ] on his door
so lonely i'm trying to like pretend to
be you guys
you need more drinks yeah
brutal jess all right you destroyed kick
you and your baby office just
[Laughter]
all right here's the next little bit of
my piece
[Applause]
here we go hi big mo girls it's michelle
um i just wanted to ask for some advice
from y'all
um
how do you know if he's the one
yeah how do you know
you guys are
like each other
thanks for the message bye how do you
know if you like somebody i don't know
he's the one the one who's the one but
how do you know if you like each other
that's what she said at the end at the
end no if you are like each other i get
or like
one more time you're like
it's michelle um i just wanted to ask
for some advice from y'all
um
how do you know if he's the one
how do you know you guys are
like each other
thanks for the message i like each other
i think it's obvious if you like each
other i mean
that part is the the easy part i think
she was just like didn't know how to say
it but like how do you know he's the one
yeah i think only the two married people
might know that because
yeah i mean i don't think any man is the
one
i'd say the most important part is make
sure your [ __ ] life values line
up like things that are cemented like
things that
you know you can change opinions on
something but your general your life
values like the core
of who you are as people what's an
example of that yeah what exactly teach
me okay so he's like i don't know if
he's the one who's stephen
we're having a great example
freedom is really important for both of
us like we really value independent
thinking
i don't have to agree with him on
everything he can disagree with me on
things and i'm enlightened to hear why
he disagrees with me and it's very
stimulating for both of us to hear each
other's opinions and to have freedom of
thought and freedom like to do the
things that we like to do there are a
lot of um people that don't like like
people think that they feel like they're
in prison when they're in a relationship
because they can't do all the things
they used to do when they were single i
mean no cheating on each other but like
you know the things you're passionate
about we like really having a personal
time yeah and so that's like a really
strong value another thing is like we're
really family oriented so like we both
had to really
value family and like want to prioritize
family and
i don't know i think those things don't
change with the wind like things can
happen like things happen throughout
your whole relationship there's many ups
and downs but those core values don't
change and i think that
when those core values are the same you
can always come back to each other
and the sex has to be good sorry it just
does yeah i don't know
like the right answer because i know i'm
not the one to give advice but i from
what i've gotten and what i'm looking
for at 34 years old is like for me to
just feel like comfortable with the
person and not that there's like a lot
of friction because i think most of my
relationships
i liked them i was attracted to them or
whatever the thing like but there was
still always like a level of discomfort
where i couldn't fully just
live my life yeah like there was some
sort of friction
and i'm like i don't know it's just not
gonna work like yeah so i think when
there's when the friction goes away i'm
hoping i'm not that you won't have
fights but like just that everyday
kind of like a little grueling thing in
the background that's kind of bugging
you and you can't just ever feel
comfortable a hundred percent that's
what i think the life goes most of my
relationships have kind of always had a
little [ __ ] nagging thing because
everything else you can work on you can
work on communication which is i think
really important in a relationship you
can work on that like but the life
values like the things like how you see
the world like if you just totally
disagree on something then you just kind
of know like you're the person in your
house is kind of your enemy right yeah
just you can't work towards the same
goal if you both see the world
completely different you'll never be
working towards something together
you'll always be like split minds on how
to
get places because you guys want to go
different places and eventually it's
going to end with you guys splitting
and so i think n having the same
viewpoint on like how you see the world
and how you how you see interacting with
people and how you should treat people
and like how you
you know view life is so important and
also i think cause she's probably really
young something that i just want to make
sure you do note is like pay attention
to a man's actions
how much effort oh yeah he's actually
pretty easy to go it's easy to say i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna do that we'll do
this we'll do that they'll never [ __ ]
they'll talk their ass off make all
kinds of promises make you waste all
your [ __ ] time you need to see
what they're doing and consistency
anyone can fake it for a couple months
yeah but can they fake it for years
probably not it's harder it's hard much
harder yeah some sociopaths can but
it's much harder can't live without them
if you can't live without steve says if
you can't live without them you just
poke dirty vision yourself living
without them if you can't live without
them but also there's infatuation for
with young p people where they think oh
i can't live without this person yeah
that but that's different right if you
can't i'm telling you if you can't live
without them like it's a different thing
to just like
yeah nice to meet you
yeah i mean you can
you can have
crushes you can have like
feelings for people but like
can you like if they if they were out of
the world like they like left the planet
like could you move on with your life i
don't know if i could
oh yeah don't you buy hello fresh
thank you for that yeah love you steve
bye you're all right stay back please
thank you
so get life insurance on them if you can
live without
that if you can't if that ceases to
exist you can't go on huh
i'm totally like yeah i really totally
love you guys
him and between him and franklin man
franklin
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
franklin doesn't lay that dick down
exactly they both have purposes and
they're both virgos oh my goodness i
can't with that
cat astrology i need to figure out what
my kids might fall i know his birth
they were born in the same yeah what's
april's 18th [ __ ] those ares cats
pisce uh taurus oh my gosh it's hard so
cute casey is a tourist oh is it a
taurus weight april 18th
well i feel like that answer was quite
long enough you don't need my input yeah
no
it goes april march nicki's still trying
to work out this cat astrology yeah no
one [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] about tiff what
do you think about
wait no
you don't want to speak on how you know
when it's the one
uh
i don't i mean the way i knew
was
just
it's the opposite of what you said
jess so for me it was like knowing that
i could keep up with the [ __ ] like
knowing that i can keep going
in the relationship and work for it
connection was strong enough that no
matter how
yeah you had to deal with where it's
like
it's like still fighting for like i
still
feel like with no other person did i
ever feel like it was worth it yeah like
you know like to go through the [ __ ]
and that was a lot of [ __ ] but like
to go through it like to feel like it's
fine it's worth it you know like there's
a certain soul connection that's like
your tie you're linked to them yeah yeah
i think maybe it's misleading where i
like there's not going to be any
[ __ ] i don't believe that there's
not going to be [ __ ] but i think
it's just like there has to like there's
at a point though like you're so
comfortable with him though right
because i like in all of my previous
relationships i don't think i was ever
really comfortable
like i couldn't just be myself i think
one aries
thank you for that
i think what i look for is someone that
makes me feel
that i am safe and protected yeah it's a
very big thing for me because like i've
navigated most of my life by myself
um but for me it's like
if i get if i lose all my limbs tomorrow
can you can i lean on you him literally
honestly honestly gina is
so maybe not that crazy but like if not
like like if we have a kid and i have
like postpartum depression or something
they can't bring myself out of bed on
those days yeah can they ride out like
two years of really hard yeah you know
something like going down can i if we
have kids can you can i trust you to
take care of the kids when i can't get
out of bed can i trust you to take care
of the house and everything when i can't
do it because like i will do it i always
will you know it's always going to be a
great partnership but i also need to
know that he's got your back yeah that
you got my back at the end of the day if
i'm so overwhelmed with life and i just
can't handle it i can run to you to keep
me safe yeah and that's such a huge
someone said like imagine you
babysitting grandkids with this person
like do they fill that
role for you like can you imagine or is
this person like you're like oh no i
don't think i'd i don't want to be
babysitting my grandkids with this
person marry your best friend too like
you guys have to have fun alone together
yeah fun alone together that's huge not
just in the yeah
yeah fun alone like you make each other
like you you are good company to each
other yeah yeah you don't get bored with
each other you're supposed to be like
attacks over dumb [ __ ] yeah just
friendships i'll just marry gina yeah
cute can i come to the wedding no
literally my life goal is to just go to
gina's wedding
i'm not going to have a big wedding she
just said she said that you lost my
dreams
yeah your birthday was so good that now
you set up expectations that you need to
fulfill nope everybody gets one that's
it we're good you got the birthday and
this is [ __ ] i invested so much in
this friendship for this one [ __ ] this i
was only your friend until the wednesday
yeah
you have a good awesome wedding i get to
go there i want to have like just like a
a an uh what is it a uh what is it the
courthouse wedding
your fancy ass having a courthouse i had
a courthouse wedding but santa barbara's
courthouse is so [ __ ] beautiful
it's like one of those yeah that one is
really nice yeah and then we went to
somewhere else for the reception yeah we
also had a courthouse wedding you know
having your courthouse wedding but then
the reception but you had a real
reception
are we talking to y'all we're talking
what are we talking about
you cannot i will start saving for my
outfit and the gifts that will help you
cannot do this to us yeah okay damn it
oh it's my friends have a look oh yes
wait wait can you would you have a
wedding in japan
oh one hundred percent oh a thousand
percent of what happened
yeah
we'll see no no no i want a a yeah
oh my god it's no boats
like her wedding is like the moment i
get engaged you guys are gonna come out
like okay so i played it out we already
got as big of a blueprint yeah we're
going here we've been interesting this
for years okay we have a meeting with
the wedding planner already we're ready
to do it we've been talking about cheryl
yeah you guys remember that show like
where they have to pick like the best
wedding out of three no so there was a
show where there's three brides and the
other brides had to attend their wedding
and they had to write everything like
okay the food was good whatever and at
the end someone wins and i they get like
some sort of prize that's going to be
you guys
i'm going to make it a reality show yeah
planning gina's wedding
[Applause]
i feel like um
jess's would be the the like most low
budget
what
yeah girl you don't know like mine
you don't know me she has to be the most
like rigid like you have to follow the
schedule
[Applause]
dude i hired a whole wedding planner to
just you do it i didn't want to do this
this is a competition oh my gosh even if
it's a competition i'm so sorry for that
i'm like you do it my teacher is
outsourcing my future husband you better
make a lot of money because we're having
a three one million dollar wedding in
japan in my head right now
what
is an
accountant for g now her man's gonna pay
for it oh god okay so sorry i'm never
gonna make a million dollars wait i want
to hear more messages oh yeah that's
right i'm carried away with my wedding
i'm so sorry yeah
they're all about that one answer
to yeah what makes someone the one
because you just know you feel it and
you're like
you're gonna have a bunch of answers too
but you have to be able to differentiate
between infatuation yeah that's the hard
part
so get really in tune with your own
intuition that's what i would advise you
to do spend a lot of time with yourself
watch and talk to get in tune with
yourself it's very close to infatuation
yeah don't get carried away by a man's
words and charisma
no you'll you'll get burned a few times
but you'll figure it out wait i just
realized so they all called in with
their real numbers these are their real
phone numbers
i'm just going to send them text
messages
is sylvia there
sylvia oh my god
if i get drunk enough enough this
episode i'm doing it no we're hiding the
numbers from jesus
yeah we're gonna call it like the two
drunk [ __ ] want to call people
australia they're
[Music]
out of
my control is annette and i've just been
a long time viewer of you guys now since
like this opened up essentially um
i just like to say that because of
youtube as you guys worked together
collectively
i've
honestly felt more like connected with
people even though like i don't leave my
house as much
it's just very comforting to know that
like i shouldn't seem like our emotions
are mutual
around like
not just me essentially
anyways uh thank you for making me feel
follow me
for helping me not feel so lonely um i
love you guys a lot so thank you i can't
hear her at all in this one she said oh
thank you for making me feel not so
lonely yeah like she basically listens
and um feels her own emotions reflected
on the podcast and then it makes her
feel which is exactly why we started it
it was like when we were talking in the
text group it was like oh sorry
microphone sorry casey um it was like
wow how many other people because i felt
crazy and then i other people in the
text group felt the same way and it was
like oh [ __ ] other people out in the
world probably feel this way and nobody
ever talks about these things
i remember early on i said that i wanted
i think we all agreed that we wanted
this podcast to feel like your older
sister you ever had yeah that's the
whole reason why we were like we got to
do this and none of us had a girlfriend
group growing up really
so
or an older sister right most of us yeah
[Music]
like i had two best friends you didn't
have that older sister vibe yeah i have
two older sisters but they lived in
mexico yeah so i'm like i technically
have that but not so when you immigrated
but yeah like so hearing these messages
and like seeing how like our vision
yeah and like we're actually fulfilling
that like that's so cool i love that we
did exactly what we wanted to yeah i'm
so happy about it makes me happy
okay big mood
first of all i am such a big fan i love
listening to the podcast
i especially love the dating profile
you see one of them maybe i don't know i
actually have
a question about it
uh but here's a little bit of backstory
i've been on the dating apps for
years now
and i have had little to no success i've
had matches
but sometimes there would be
bots and you know scams and stuff like
that that sucks yeah
sometimes i'd match with real people
but it's never been
it's never gone to the point where it's
like let's go on a date or you know it
end up being like
let's just be friends or whatever
and sometimes when i'm swiping through
um
if there's
social media attached to it i'll screen
shoot the profile and look back at it
later to see their social media you know
it's like
um
that so-and-so has their instagram or
their snapchat or whatever attached
and uh
the that whole shindig anyway
i was thinking because i was deleting
screenshots
from
like old profiles
storage space
and i was wondering
should i
should i continue
swiping through the dating app space or
should i just rely on
my
in-person social life to
find a partner because i've
been on there for years but i'm also
only 21 now oh
you got a long time i'm almost 22 i'm
ready to give up i don't know
am i too old for it not too long
am i
going about this the wrong way
or
you know you are baby you're asking 30
year old 21 thank you so much yeah to
hear from you very soon okay so he's
definitely not having luck on the dating
apps okay but it doesn't mean he has a
sleeve he is baby yeah
that's what he says
he needs to he needs to get discouraged
guys that like know how to talk to girls
because whatever he's doing it's not
it's not translating wow oh my god oh my
god that's my it's wine time it's one
o'clock
stop it stop it
do you know the waves
look like it was your make sure you stop
and not snooze
she she was getting up that way just for
wine
i was looking for an excuse and that was
a perfect time yeah yeah excuse to get
wine but i'll just continue i think that
like he needs to try to find guys that
like you've got to know some guys in
your life that's like somewhere at work
at somewhere that have success with
ladies kind of ask them what they're
doing because like taking advice from
girls may or may not necessarily work
like for you exactly i don't know i
don't know what you're doing i don't
know like what's causing you to not have
luck but you need to get with some guys
that are in your real life and ask them
how they're going about it what they're
doing gina jesus christ well and also
the the dating pool at that age too i
don't know how many people are looking
for serious relationships or if people
are i don't think that matters
that doesn't matter he should still be
able to get matches if he's doing like
the right stuff
well 91 dates he's not getting dates
yeah because it really sounds like he's
just gotten discouraged from the apps
all together so he's like wait should i
just be looking for people in my
personal life and yeah sure to me that
that sounds like a little duck kind of
thing yeah like of course you want to
meet people that are in person for me
personally like i've never done the
dating app world so
personally i would just like not even go
there but if you're already doing that
then just keep doing that if that's an
option for you you've got nothing to
lose but i can't even actually you can't
do what you're doing now though it's not
working like stop doing whatever you're
doing now you got to do something
totally different no i just want to
change your approach i want to look at
all your messages i know i i want to
review your dating process
that you send because of you yeah
anything like this
yeah
if you just say like hey
like that's not you we should do another
dating profile
yeah send us what you would send as an
icebreaker yeah
and then something's happening like he's
not good at like conversing or something
well she's sending things like once in
my dick
i don't think so okay come on obviously
that's not gonna work i don't think
that's weird i don't think that's what's
happening i think it's just like being
too awkward or too fresh because even in
person like being awkward like that can
work for some women like you just gotta
find your person and i think like just
don't give up and eventually you'll find
the person that you'll vibe with in
person if that's how it happens and if
it's gonna be through dating apps and
yeah i think you're gonna have to take
it more serious and definitely change up
what you're doing yeah but definitely
don't get sucked into some like um
pickup artist [ __ ] like don't do
that oh my god if you ever like pick up
artists should be bullied all the time
yeah i mean go to like real guys in your
real life that get laid
um
also if in the meantime while you
haven't found somebody i'll give you
something to listen to and that is dipsy
one of our sponsors they are a sexy
stories audio app everyone needs an
escape but those can be hard to come by
right now especially if you're not
having luck on the dating apps enter
dipsy let yourself get lost in a world
where good things happen and where your
pleasure is the only priority
dipsy is an audio audio app full of
short sexy stories designed to turn you
on
each dipsy audio stories features
characters that feel like real people
and immersive scenarios so you feel like
you're right there i just like words
listen to stories about hooking up with
your hometown crush that you never made
a move on or that co-worker you always
had a little thing for or maybe a story
that puts you to bed with someone
turning on exactly why is my background
they release new content every week so
there's always more to explore no matter
who you're into or what turns you on my
tongue is so bored right now
dipsy also has wellness sessions
consensual bedtime stories and
soundscapes
for guys to just say my throat so bored
right now
my throat is so big
for our listeners dipsy is offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood
dipsy stories dot com slash mood yes and
if you would like if you would like to
get in the mood on some nice sheets
try editude yes the dirty little not so
secret about the bedding aisle is that
while cotton might be the most popular
fabric for sheets duvets and pillowcases
it's also the most damaging to our
planet
that's why i am so excited to introduce
you to etitude which offers sustainably
made bedding sleepwear bath wear and
accessories all made from 100 organic
bamboo fabric i love these i freaking
slip i [ __ ] run and jump into my bed
every day
the best sheets i've ever had in my
entire life i never want any other type
of sheet after 21 years old stop having
those bed like get rid of those bed
sheets i feel like t-shirts yeah yes it
was like target
dudes
yeah like if i just met you i would
sleep in your bed just based on your
sheets alone like i was not going to
spend the night but now i don't know i'm
just leaving
you stuck with me they're so freaking
soft like how does bamboo get that i
don't know it's how and it stays so cool
too pandas is so good it's the best
unlike cotton unlike cotton which
consumes massive amounts of water energy
and chemicals during prescription during
production attitude uses organic bamboo
the most resource efficient plant on our
planet ettitude's 100 organic bamboo
fabric has a unique silky smooth and
feathery soft texture that's similar to
silk it delivers unparalleled comfort
that actually feels better than cotton i
will put my name on that 100 stamp it
yes try any attitude betting for 30
nights if you're not completely
satisfied return it for a full refund
right now you can get 20 don't return it
um
yeah i'll take it if you don't like it
i'll take it right now you can get
twenty percent off your order plus free
shipping when you visit etitude.com mood
and enter promo code mood remember
that's attitude as in eco attitude order
today for free shipping and 20 off your
order at etitude.com
mood promo code mood yeah
get in get into those sheets if i see
those cheap sheets those those t-shirts
yeah
i'm like [ __ ] this and that thin like
terry blanket or whatever yeah invest in
your sleep people mm-hmm and just in
your bed if you want girls in it true
or boys
oh my gosh hi
okay as a virgo i was going to write
down what i wanted to say i love virgos
this one's going to be different i'm
just going to talk
so first of all really excited to call
in feels like i'm calling into a radio
show
i kind of wish i was calling into racial
so i could win something
you win our hearts yeah podcast
i love listening to the floor you speak
so much fun i listen to it while i'm on
my hot girl walks
i would like to share a quote that i
like to tell myself
it's from the sixth book of a series of
unfortunate events the elevator book and
i don't know why i want to share it but
it's one of my favorite things
and maybe it'll help someone
in the sixth book
the three baudelaire orphans have to
like go down an empty elevator
like there's no elevator there's just
like a hole
so
i think it's violent it says
if we wait until we're ready we'll be
waiting for the rest of our lives and
whenever i find myself in a situation
where i'm like wait i'm not ready
i just think
if we wait until we're ready
i'm never gonna feel prepared
but yeah thank you for all that you do
thank you for sharing your life
with us
really appreciate it you're the best
send me lots of love
um yeah bye
oh we love that dude
that's so cool we spend all of our time
giving you guys advice this one is like
you know what i want to share something
with you too and that's yeah
yeah
wait what was her name i didn't catch it
i don't think she said anything her name
i she she said virgo she's a virgo yeah
virgo listener out there and way to go
for not scripting it just going off the
cuff like that's awesome i mean like
it's just like the same message yeah it
went really well yeah yeah exactly and
that's i think people are so scared of
everything going wrong that that's why
they never take that leap they never
feel she just did and you just did and
proved like that
obviously it can go very right and even
if it goes wrong you learn something
yeah i think people um well i don't
think i know because there's statistics
and studies that say that people that
are at the end of the line like they're
on their deathbed they when they're
asked with the what they regret the most
they
more so regret the things they didn't do
than the things that they did yeah and
most people wish they could go back and
do all those things and so
don't wait till you're ready just do it
if you mess up you mess up you learn and
you move on i think it's super endearing
that she decided to give us advice
because i posted something on my
instagram the other day saying
um
the the what is it the healer needs
healing the giver needs giving the
planner needs surprises and stuff like
that too and we are the ones who have
been just putting us ourselves out there
and then this one comes along it's like
hey you know what like i want to i care
about you enough to give you something
also and that actually makes my heart
really i love that gina loves gifts too
thank you so much even gifts of the
heart i dare you make me cry you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] friends
she doesn't like that yes
don't make her feel she's a little [ __ ]
girl a little baby [ __ ]
then the advice that she decided to
share too like
because i've heard um because i saw the
show the series of unfortunate events so
i they say that quote in the show too
but i don't know for some reason like
her telling me right now i'm like you're
right yeah
yeah yeah
sometimes you need to hear it it's
impactful from a different person yeah
yeah yeah from an actual real person not
something just like on your tv this is a
real person yeah because there's so many
things right now that i'm like no no not
now and this was specifically for us not
like a tv show but this was sent
specifically for us i have your phone
number [ __ ] i'm going to [ __ ] call
you we're going to call you i'm going to
prank call you later
i'm drunk
okay you said that i'm closing the
laptop we're not afraid we're not drunk
i jumped on elevator shafts
i wasn't ready but it was really fun
no i'm not doing that
thank you
thank you yeah
all right next
honey
if they stand up normal um i guess my
question would be um
when do i let go
of
my ex i guess even
we did it through high school and then i
had to move away from college and then
now i'm back we're so good it's just
i don't know
we're like at different parts of our
lives
she's working doing community college
oh my gosh
please give advice thank you
yeah you know in your heart it's so hard
though and it's easier said than done
but you're going to feel so much better
knowing that you made the right decision
because i can just tell by the way
you're saying this that you know
just you're in different places you i
mean it's not the right time even if you
were meant to video it's just not the
right time you guys are
like you need to learn live your lives
separately right now what's that term uh
sunken cost or something or like what is
it yeah yeah i feel like that's kind of
what she's feeling where it's like so
much time together and like so much
growth you also gravitate towards what's
familiar because yeah we as humans are
biologically like more scared scared of
the unknown yeah that's the whole like
that last voice message about taking a
leap of faith basically is like counter
intuitive to what we're naturally
progressing just stay in your team be
risk at first yeah like don't like don't
stay with what you know even if it's not
as good for you like even if it doesn't
make you happy it's more familiar than
the unknown that's just also that first
time like you know from her first love
for through high school and college that
first time like really ripping off that
band-aid of like really letting someone
go permanently is so hard it's like a
childhood it's so like you have to get
through this it's going to make you
stronger it's going to make it easier
for the next time it has to happen but
like yeah
happiness too
it's going to make you feel stronger
later and you'll appreciate it later the
pain that you're going through now but
you just have to get through it brings
more depth to your
life experience yeah to go through these
things we've all had to feel the pain
like so all the nights of like wondering
was it the right thing was it the wrong
thing like it hurts yeah like you kind
of wish you could just take it back or
you wish you could do more i can tell
you if you're having any of these doubts
it yeah like you're not supposed to be
with that person yeah like you wouldn't
wonder
if you were supposed to stay on the
other hand too it's like
right like like you guys said earlier
maybe it's just not the right time you
know like you guys are
going your separate ways i believe in
the the red string thing where it's like
uh you and your soul mate are connected
by a red string and it might get tangled
you know separate or whatever
in the middle of life or whatever but
you're always connected so right now
maybe
your lives through red strings are a
little bit entangled and everything else
you have to find yourself get your life
together and then maybe you guys will
find each other at the end you know so
you're supposed to learn different
things right yeah you're supposed to
have different experiences like you can
feel it in your gut you're not supposed
to be with this person right now so if
it's meant to be it will end up meaning
to be it'll always find its way yeah
yeah you're in a string entanglement i
just want to say though most likely not
like and that needs to be okay
you have to let this person like go and
kind of grow up and move on and like
live the next chapter of your life like
just living thinking oh well i'll just
come back to it later like it's that
security blanket that doesn't
necessarily need to exist yeah it's to
me
saying it that way makes it feel like
less of a security blanket like well i'm
throwing it to the wind you know if it
comes back to me cool but i'm letting it
go completely like but you have to let
go you have to let go completely because
when i remember
there was one relationship i've talked
about several times on this show before
but we were together for five years i
almost got married to this guy and it
just didn't feel right and there was
nothing wrong with our relationship it
was very comfortable but it just didn't
feel like
i couldn't picture being stuck with him
for the next it felt like stuck with him
for the next 40 or however long we live
and i was like i just feel like it's not
the right choice but there's no
thing that's wrong you know i just don't
feel right so i have to follow my gut
and i've always followed my gut even
when it doesn't feel even when like on
paper it seems right and i always said
at that time and to make me feel better
you know because it was really emotional
still because i
loved him as a friend and i like i felt
like i loved him but i wasn't in love
with him right and that's the hardest
thing especially when they didn't do
anything wrong and they still love you
and
it was like in my head i the same thing
you said was
um like i love him if it's meant to be
we'll find each other again
but i didn't feel like it was meant to
be at that point like this girl might
though she might think that but like oh
it's just kind of you just gotta
completely let it go yeah because
what's yours is yours though like it's
coming yeah yeah like what is meant for
you it's gonna come anyway so
like and you can really tell too once
you let it go like once he moved away to
a different town
i didn't miss him
and i was like that's really telling
because i thought once you give it space
and because like we said earlier it's
like if you can't live without them
that's the one like the one that like
where
you both feel that way too not an
infatuation thing where you're like i'm
obsessed with this person i can't live
without them no but i mean like like you
really like feel like they you both have
such a deep understanding of your like
you're supposed to be together it's like
this thing like he will also be fighting
for it and like if you're both not also
fighting for both people have to be
fighting for it if it's just one it's
infatuation yeah good luck yeah i love
you we love you
you can do it you can do it you're gonna
make so much life and you will not doubt
it'll be okay
you'll
you will not regret it later i [ __ ]
promise you yeah because yeah with the
not regretting it later like later you
might find someone that really you feel
a connection or like with gino's saying
later you might reconnect and it was a
better time yeah you won't regret this
time now that you're taking
you want exactly if you live it hi hi my
name is jillian and i'm 22
i just wanted to thank you guys for all
the helpful advice throughout your
podcast from
feminine hygiene to how to find red
flags in men
you guys really crack me up like i swear
all the time and and um it helps time go
by faster when i'm bored at work so
thank you for being the most amazing
hilarious beautiful group of girls and
putting a smile on my face
um i actually
wanted to ask some for some advice
on how to get over someone you were in
love with kill him um
i've tried everything to forget about my
ex but i always seem to go back to the
happy memories and perfect times we had
we broke up after three years from
arguing a lot and never fixing our
mistakes and problems in a healthy way
our arguments were always over something
super dumb and that always would
escalate real fast and in the end he he
gave up on trying which i understand but
i just can't seem to forget the good
times
i know i'm young but i was really in
love with him and can't really see
myself with anyone else
i'm still struggling every day to keep
my head above the water so any advice
would really be helpful
thanks guys p.s can't wait for the burst
of adorable baby tips and cake
listen this is what i always do i i know
i mean i'm sure we all did this whenever
we go through a breakup we always
remember all the good times yeah and you
just never start thinking oh you never
think about
the bad thing it takes a lot of time can
i say i actually read a professional
study that um
it's a coping mechanism it's a
biological coping mechanism that is also
triggered when you when someone dies
that you're close to that you when you
lose somebody it's like it's so that
your body
doesn't go into like devastation mode
you remember only the good times so
you're when you break up with someone
that you loved or that you got broken up
with like your body does the same thing
as if you lost them like they died and
so you only remember
the good memories of survival yeah
exactly it's like a survival coping
mechanism thing so that you can
go move on yeah but sometimes it you're
like wait body this hurts more yeah yeah
it makes me stop
reminding me how shitty they were yeah
that's exactly what happens whenever you
break up you're like oh but this this
was so great and you were remembering
all the good stuff but the thing is you
guys broke up for a reason he gave up on
you for a reason all those little small
things that you guys argued about
husband's not going to give up on you
honey exactly your husband will not give
up it's hard to keep track of that in
your head so what i actually do is i
write down a list of pros and cons
and a lot of these times when we break
up the list of cons outweighs the list
of pros it's just hard to remember that
right now because you're in a lot of
pain but that's emotional thinking you
have to go through it logically and
write it down and just realize like oh
these are all the cons it's hard for me
to see that now but logically it's right
there
and and then you'll you just refer back
to that and then you'll realize like
yeah this is actually you know this is
okay and remember how you remember those
cons and
think about how you would have to deal
with those cons for the rest of your
life
but when you're in that phase though
you're like i'll deal with anything i
just need him back it's a chemical
reaction in your brain i think a little
bit of what this is is like her life
outside of him is not fulfilling enough
at the moment yeah like you need to you
need to fill your life with things that
that are valuable other than this person
yeah that are attached you're just
relying on him for all of your dopamine
and all of your like chemical things
that give you a little zing every day
the dopamine the serotonin
got it all from him all the memories you
replaying that [ __ ] in your head you're
just like you're basically like doing
the love addiction thing where you're
just like i can't let him go because
like you're getting those dopamine hits
just even thinking about him like
wishing he was there and like but you
gotta
actually build a life
that's whole and that's the hardest
thing and it doesn't make sense you're
not even gonna know what the [ __ ] i'm
saying i didn't figure that out for like
until just like a year ago
like that your life happened we're
actually 30. like yeah it's going to be
a long your 20s are going to [ __ ]
suck yeah i'm sorry it's going to be
that's true but you have to keep
learning all the [ __ ] in the 20s you
just have to keep trying like it this is
a tumultuous time of your life you're
not going to feel settled and good about
yourself and like able to handle these
crazy wild relationships things until
you get a little older it's not even
perfect in your 30s it's not you're
always constantly learning yeah but it's
it's way i remember it was way harder oh
yeah it was like oh yeah like you got
you're ripping all these band-aids off
for the first time and it's tough and
you just got to know like we all did it
mm-hmm you're not this is not special or
different or like i'm sorry but this we
all did it you're gonna make your other
finances relationships yeah you're right
like all that stuff you're working on
one at a time in your 20s it's like all
coming together because you're just
thrown into the [ __ ] they say your
20s are your best time i don't think
your twenties are your best friend no
i'm just way happier now this is
absolute [ __ ] you're going through it
yeah it's probably worse than you'd be i
didn't believe 30 year olds when they
were telling me like that they were
having a better time because i was like
but you're old yeah but i'm like no i
thought they were saying that just to
make themselves feel better like a liar
oh my god it's so much better because
like i wouldn't trade anything i
wouldn't go back to that to like the the
innocence of the pain of the first time
of some of these experiences is just so
wrong so devastating i love you i'm
sorry i know it hurts like you'll get
there i promise you yeah that's much
better over here we have cookies yeah
yeah
oh my god and then you're getting the
wine you have all this knowledge but
then you also have money yeah so good
it's so good and you have like coping
mechanisms yeah like strategies tools
under your belt like less destructive
ones like going out and drinking too you
know and you give less [ __ ] yeah it's
all coming together baby it's gonna be
okay it's a nice soup of healthy
emotions let us envelop you in our in
our old age
seriously come to the other side make it
through we feast off your youth
god
sanders and sisters jesus
but yeah you know what for that one make
a list see what happens i can almost
guarantee you that the consoles is going
to be longer yeah well i don't know if
she's being honest with you send me the
list because i could make that same list
about all the guys that i've broken up
with and i'm like but none of these
things matter because you know i just
love it so much yeah anything that's on
that list like nikki said look at it and
ask yourself do you want to deal with
that for the rest of your life and the
rest of your life with kids it gets days
after day
and also letting go of someone or not
being able to let go of someone who's
already let you go um yeah yeah like
love yourself more girls your husband
you want someone that values you
you can love you love him but love
yourself you would never want to be with
someone that doesn't value value
trust go read like the dead bedroom's
reddit get back oh my god
go check it out i didn't even know that
was a thing come back girl dead bedrooms
dead bedrooms sounds kinky no it's not
oh it's dead that's necrophilia it's
dead enough anyways ophelia
to the rest and then prank phone call
after jess goes to bed no you're not
pranking phone calling i'm calling
someone
i already remembered like memorize one
of the numbers
no but thank you so much for sticking
with us for through 100 episodes that's
crazy or even if you just joined
thank you and stick around for the next
hundred yeah
yeah we love that guys
go buy attitude sheets for real yeah
it's like for real though
you make me cry on camera yeah
stop looking at my titties
[Music]
you